so I've now seen you more than some of
my friends which is awesome yeah so I
guess Before we jump into this that
sonic footage was cool and Jem looks
like he is playing Jim Carrey like in
one of these movies again it's awesome
well good I'm glad that that was your
response to cuz it definitely was mine I
just didn't know if it was because I was
so close to the project but it was I
think one of the most fun things about
the movie is getting to see him after
ten years of being in film come back and
have a blast you know what I mean like
clearly he's he's you're getting to see
everything that we love about him and
yet everything still feels new and fresh
and not like anything he's done before
specifically but his you know his
wheelhouse and getting to see him enjoy
himself doing that again is a special
thing to be on the receiving end of sure
I'm also imagining that on set just
getting to watch him work as a fan of
his work yeah he's a very unique and
talented person it is unlike anybody
I've ever seen in that he is a specific
brand of comedy and thing that he does
and he mastered and to sit back and kind
of watch that it's ironic that he plays
this you know sort of crazy overzealous
doctor robotnik in the movie because on
set he can sort of be that way sort of
like this um you know he's like in his
laboratory like creating jokes and
creating things to do in the scene and
constantly elevating what's on the page
so it was a great learning experience
for me to watch him and see how he works
and you know and again I grew up as a
fan like he was he's one of my comedic
heroes so to be like sharing scenes with
him and watching him work was you know I
went home calling all my friends and
family telling them about how it was
it's very special Jenica do I get to
talk to you so I watch I finished the
show last night you did I did you start
last night no I started two days ago
it's like they're only 30 minute
episodes actly you can watch it all in
one day it's five hours it's really not
hard yeah well at least for me but
anyway yeah so this show though is load
with twists and turns yeah when you were
told about the show were they like yeah
every episode we're peeling back some of
the onion yeah I think with something
like this it reminded me of the format
which we took in West world which was
here's the first episode and here's a
conversation with the showrunner and the
writer to explain kind of where your
character goes throughout the season not
not in great detail but enough to go hey
you know is this exciting to you to go
on this path with this guy
so there's still you know with each
script that you get like oh that happens
okay cool you know surprises for you as
someone who's involved in the project
and that's that's kind of exciting you
don't get that on a film because you get
the script beginning to end before you
start shooting on a movie you know and
that might change a little bit here and
there along the way but with a series
you don't really know every little you
don't see everything every rock
overturned you know so you really didn't
know like where it was all going
I knew the sort of I knew where my
character ends up sure let's say and and
a few little pin you know little points
along the way what what are little
little bits here and there but like I
didn't know it was plenty I didn't know
it's but that way completely I really
was watching the first four or five
episodes are loaded with like holy [ __ ]
moments like that
what yeah I mean sorry for the language
but yeah I know no I like when that
happens I'm like okay good I can do the
same thing yeah it's it's you know it's
this kind of show where it's there are
these cliffhangers and a little
surprises here and there like you don't
want any of that to like get out I don't
know I think nowadays it's so easy to
spread information me like you know yes
boil things for people and we haven't
spoiled it yet but you know I hope that
it keeps you know I think the best
experience for watching a show like this
or a film is to just know nothing you
know nothing about it this way I
actually watch it like I don't know what
to expect you know what this show is
about it's a couple of actors and
actresses in the movie that I like
go I hit play on this knowing I was
doing the junket no zero and I think
that helped it happens on like you know
when the Oscars roll around and the big
movies come out and I'm late to seeing
them all it affects your experience
watching them once something gets
praised and like it's the greatest movie
in the world it it may very well have
been had you not heard about that if you
get to discover it yourself it has a
different effect on you but you watch it
later than everyone else you're like
yeah it's a good movie you know but like
it's a huge part of it so that we I like
that we kind of take care of and nurture
the experience as more than just sitting
down and watching it you know like my
last thing for you because I'm out of
time I cannot what is it like getting a
phone call from Quentin or whoever
contacted you to say by the way oh he
wants you to be in like this massive
movie I mean it's definitely like a
bucket list check for sure and like my
first my first response is do they have
the right James so yeah that was that
was something that was like Falcon dream
you know was and I would have extensive
conversations with him and I'm talking
about you know what I was doing and who
the guy was and and just sitting back
and watching him explain something and
to illustrate something with his his
language it's like man this is a show
unto itself how much did you pay to be
in the movie oh just my firstborn right
okay I got a stop there but man Congrats
on being that and everything else thank
you
you know what I mean have a fantastic
day you do nice to see you in a couple
of days yeah exactly